- Dad, what's gonna happen if
I put diesel fuel in my car?
(playful guitar music)
Dad.
- Hey, Dad.
- Dad, I'm at a party and
I need to plunge a toilet.
- Dad, what's a dipstick?
- What the hell is in
the back of a toilet?
Dad, which remote turns on my TV?
My lights went off.
How do I turn them back on?
I'm trying to watch Bachelorette.
Will I get electrocuted if I touch this
circuit breaker board light thing?
- Hey, Dad, how many plugs
can I put in an outlet
before it becomes dangerous?
Can we sue him for that?
- What's a Roth IRA?
- Can they sue us for that?
- Well, what's a 401K?
- I wasn't peeing in public.
- Can I have more money?
- If the engine light went off by itself,
does that mean it's fixed?
- Dad, do we have AAA?
- Dad, if I've never changed
my oil, is that a bad thing?
Hey, Dad.
When did you know you wanted to marry Mom?
- Hey.
- Hey, what's up?
- What are you doing out here?
- Just talking to my dad.
- We're gonna be late.
- Okay
- [Woman] Come on.
- Hey, Dad, I gotta go.
(slow cheerful guitar music)